[Musique]
rachida faisait courir les foules et ça
a été le coup de foudre dès le début
dans les grands festivals
il s'est produit autant au festival de
jazz co franco
il y avait une foule incroyable et
d'autre part le public qui était là
c'est un public était magnifique non
seulement il était magnifique en
quantité mais aussi en qualité
c'est rare se sevrer mélange de public
comme l'acheteur pouvait la tirrenia
ce chanteur qui a commencé sa carrière
avec le groupe carte de séjour dans les
années 80 avait ce talent cette habileté
à mélanger les styles musicaux du rock
au punk en passant par le pop et même le
chat [ __ ] maghreb en alternant entre sa
langue maternelle l'arabe et le français
au manga j il est devenu en quelque
sorte le porte étendard des immigrants
en france surtout ceux de deuxième
génération
c'est clair que lui a influencé
plusieurs artistes il nous a aidés à
vouloir comprendre l'autre aussi il a
aidé une bd avec la chanson s'appelle li
harraga suggestions sur l'exil sur la
blessure que l'ess l'exil donc à peu
près tous les immigrants de deuxième
génération même si l'impôt du monde
arabe sont touchés par cette chanson là
en 2004 sa reprise de rock the casbah de
clash est un succès radiophonique
il y avait ajouté une touche de musique
raï
le chanteur d'origine algérienne a été
emporté par un malaise cardiaque à l'âge
de 59 ans il travaille à un nouvel album
qui pourrait sortir prochainement
ici à l'ombre d'un orage au canada
montréal
là
[Musique]
les yeux